si sonia dridi notre correspondante à
washington sonia bonsoir on peut dire
que c'était une allocution courte 10
minutes à peu près d'allocutions de la
part de joe biden qui donc a bien
confirmé qu'il allait débloquer une aide
supplémentaire à l'ukraine pour de
nouveaux systèmes de défense antiaériens
mais donc pas d'engagement pour une zone
d'exclusion aérienne comme le
demandaient zemsky ce matin
oui tout à fait le président by donne a
déclaré nous avons entendu l'appel de
l'ukraine pour plus d il a annoncé donc
cette aide supplémentaire de 800
millions de dollars alors il a donné des
détails sur cette assistante sécuritaire
il y aura notamment la livraison à
l'ukraine de 9000 système anti char de
7000 armements légers pour les hommes et
les femmes at il dit qui défendent leur
ville ils les états unis vont aussi
fournir des drones à l'ukraine et
quelques 20 millions de cartouches joe
biden qui a répété l'engagement des
états unis à défendre l'ukraine à être
du côté de ceux qui souhaitent la
liberté at il dit en effet il n'a pas il
ne s'est tu ne s'est pas prononcé en
faveur d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne
ce que a réclamé ce matin le président
ukrainien devant le congrès alors il ne
fallait pas s'attendre à un changement
de politique fondamentale de joe biden
parce que l'administration baden l'a dit
et répété elle ne veux pas entraîner les
états unis dans ce qui le ce que joe
biden appellerait une troisième guerre
mondiale et on sent que la maison
blanche marche vraiment en ce moment sur
un fil parce que elle veut dire son
soutien à l'ukraine et elle promet donc
d'envoyer de plus d'armes encore à
l'ukraine mais
le joe biden l'a dit et répété il n'y
aura pas d'avion américain ou de troupes
américaines en ukraine alors toutefois
c'est vrai que plus les images de civils
qui sont bombardés par les rues ces
biens sont sur nos écrans on sent que
washington fait face à plus en plus des
près dé de pressions de la part du
président ukrainien mais aussi d'élus
américains et d'ailleurs ce matin le
président ukrainien lnd qui s'est
adressé directement à baden en disant
vous êtes le leader d'une grande nation
j'aimerais que vous soyez le leader du
monde et le leader du monde et bien doit
aussi être le leader pour la paix sonia
de nom au congrès de nombreux députés
représentant en tout cas républicains
mais aussi démocrates sont favorables à
un envoi d'avions militaires à l'ukraine
mais pour l'instant du côté de la maison
blanche c'est non
oui tout à fait c'est vrai que depuis le
début de saintes avant une invasion
russe en ukraine et bien le congrès est
un relais influents pour kiev auprès de
la maison blanche et des élus des deux
bords il y a eu ni terreur à au congrès
dans la réponse à moscou donc des
républicains des démocrates ont déjà
exhorté joe biden à faciliter la
livraison par exemple d avion polonais
mig-29 à l'ukraine ce week-end le
week-end dernier il y a quatre élus qui
se sont rendus en pologne et donc ses
élus presse aussi la maison blanche de
fournir des avions de combat à l'ukraine
donc il ya une vraie pression du congrès
d'ailleurs c'est le congrès aussi qui
avait poussé la maison blanche récemment
à mettre en place un embargo sur
l'énergie russe c'est pour ça que le
président ukrainien ce matin quand il
s'est adressé aux élus et bien il a
profité de l'admiration qu'il suscite
auprès des parlementaires pour tenter de
demander plus des états unis il l'a fait
de façon assez habile il a par exemple
dit fait référence au discours de martin
luther king junior en dix ans l aveu de
rim j'ai un rêve aller à venise j'ai un
besoin j'ai besoin que vous fermiez le
ciel mais comme on vient de le dire et
bien pour l'instant la position de la
maison blanche ne change pas merci sonia
sonia dridi en direct de washington et
comme vous le disiez vous